If you don’t have prior experience learning
foreign languages, then starting a new language
for the first time can be a really challenging
task.
Even if you’re motivated, things aren’t
easy.
At the beginning, lots of motivation and little
direction typically leads to a bookshelf full
of unused language books, a phone full of
unopened apps, and a learning schedule that’s
all over the place—that is, if you spend
any time learning at all.
Instead, most of your time is spent thinking.
Or rather, worrying.
You worry to yourself, asking questions like:
Which resource should start with?
When should I start?
How often should I sit down to learn?
How long should each of my learning sessions
be?
You’ve probably found most of these questions
hard to answer, especially if you don’t
have outside help.
Where usually you could rely on a teacher
or tutor to provide solutions, learning independently
has left you with little to rely on other
than yourself.
But it doesn’t have to be that way.
With the right guide, and the right plan,
you can learn any language, even in the comfort
of your own home, far away from any language
classroom.
Hello, I am Luca Lampariello, I am a language
coach who speaks 14 languages.
On this channel, I help people learn foreign
languages more efficiently, faster, and in
a fun way.
Today, I’d like to share three simple steps
that you can put to use today, to help you
begin learning a new language—the smart
way!
Let’s dive right in!
Step 1: Get the Right Resources
When you’re just starting out in a language,
the most obvious thing to worry about is which
learning resources you will use.
It doesn’t take more than a quick Google
search to reveal that for nearly any language
you want to learn, there are hundreds of books,
apps, courses, podcasts, flashcard decks,
and more, all intended to help you learn that
language.
This might seem like a good thing, but the
sheer abundance of available learning materials
makes it impossible to navigate between them,
and choose which ones are actually ideal for
your own needs.
So, despite the great number of resources,
most people get stuck at this stage, and struggle
to move forward.
While there are many characteristics that
you could possibly look for in a good language
resource, I recommend that you focus on resources
that have two traits in particular.
When choosing a language resource, aim for
materials that are:
Comprehensible (that is, they feature language
that is appropriate for your skill level)
Interesting (that is, they feature content
that you find engaging or compelling).
Resources that meet these two conditions are
most likely to keep you both challenged and
engaged for the longest period of time, which
will allow for the most learning to take place.
In my experience, I’ve found that learning
materials with authentic, bilingual texts
in my target language are the ones that most
often meet the comprehensible and interesting
criteria.
This goes for me, and the hundreds of language
learners I’ve coached personally.
Why are bilingual texts so important?
Because having the text in both your target
language and native language (or a language
you know well) will help you compare and contrast
the structure of both languages.
This comparison will help you gradually gain
an understanding of how each language works
in relation to the other.
This type of comparison is something that
you’ll do in your head (with or without
a bilingual text), but having the texts in
front of you makes it a smoother, more painless
process.
As a beginner, you’ll want to look for bilingual
texts that feature short, natural dialogues
in your target language, along with audio
of those dialogues—even better if the dialogues
also come with things like a vocabulary list
and simple grammar explanations.
These extra tools will help quickly clarify
any words or grammar points that are difficult
to grasp solely from examining both texts.
There are a number of resources on the market
today that have all of the features I’ve
described, but I’m personally quite fond
of using Assimil’s “With Ease” series
for just this purpose.
Assimil is a French company that provides
language coursebooks in a wide range of language
combinations.
These coursebooks are jam-packed with short,
funny dialogues that I’ve found enjoyable
across many different languages.
If you can’t find Assimil in your language,
feel free to check the description box for
a link to my resources page, where you can
find many other beginner resources that I
recommend.
Step 2: Get Organized
Another important thing to keep in mind if
you want to start learning a language successfully
is to get organized and stay organized from
the very beginning and for a long time.
Contrary to what you might think, language
learning is a marathon.
It isn’t something that you can just do
for a few weeks or months, reach the level
you want, and then just forget about it.
If you don’t use your language skills, you
lose them, so it’s of the utmost importance
that before you start, you prepare yourself
to learn every day, over a long period of
time, and the most important aspects of this
preparation are threefold:
You must:
Create a learning space
Organize a regular learning schedule
Cultivate a strong mindset
For my learning space, I make sure to keep
a clean, organized, and distraction-free area
of my room where I can, you know, sit down
every day and learn languages.
I learn in the same spot every day, so as
to train my brain that this is the spot where
learning happens.
Your learning space can be anywhere you’d
like, however I’d recommend you try to keep
it as free of distractions as possible, and
that you learn in that same location every
time.
For my learning schedule, I try to keep things
consistent and organized as well.
Specifically, I learn at the same time every
day, and almost always for the same amount
of time.
This helps make learning a habit.
For added benefit, I do this at the time of
day when I have the most energy, so that I
can focus better and more easily.
For your learning schedule, aim for a daily
time slot of at least thirty to forty-five
minutes, when you feel most awake and alert.
Try not to skip it—if you do, definitely
don’t skip two days, as you risk breaking
your learning habit altogether.
For my mindset, I focus on discipline over
motivation.
Motivation is unreliable.
Some days you’ve got enough to take on the
world, other days, it’s nowhere to be found.
When embarking on a challenging, long-term
process like language learning, motivation
usually ebbs and flows in unpredictable ways,
meaning you can rarely plan on having it when
you need it.
Instead of motivation, I rely on discipline.
Discipline is about showing up every day,
whether you “feel like it” or not.
It’s about putting in the time, and putting
in the effort, even if you’re not quite
seeing the results you expect.
In a word, it’s about consistency, which,
if you noticed, is a core part of my learning
space, my learning schedule, and my mindset.
If you’re feeling low on discipline, you
might be wondering how you can get some, too.
Here’s a strategy I’ve often used that
you can try out yourself:
If you don’t have enough motivation to start
a difficult task (like language learning),
you can generate discipline by developing
a starting ritual.
A starting ritual is a simple routine that
you can practice that trains your brain to
think “ok, now it’s time to get started!”
Your starting ritual can be anything, but
I prefer short, meditative activities that
I can do anywhere.
In particular, before starting each of my
language learning sessions, I like to:
Do one minute of breathing exercises
Do one minute of walking around the room
And sit down at my learning space
Once I’ve done my breathing and walking
exercises, then I know that sitting down is
the signal to get started learning.
It sounds simple—and it is!—but these
kinds of starting rituals can be quite effective
at getting started, even when motivation is
low.
If you build the habit of starting even when
you don’t feel like it, then you’re cultivating
discipline, which will be an invaluable tool
along your learning journey.
Step 3: Reflect on Your Progress Every Day
As I said before, learning a language is a
process of long-term growth.
Though you are learning every day, the steady
progress you are making can be difficult—or
impossible—to see.
If you can’t see your progress, it can be
easy to become demotivated.
And though I said earlier that I don’t rely
on motivation, I do believe it’s important
to watch out for demotivation.
If left unchecked, demotivation often causes
people to give up, and stop learning altogether.
To avoid the trap of demotivation, it’s
important to make your progress visible, and
to review it regularly.
I do this through keeping a language learning
notebook.
Now, I say “notebook”, but what I really
mean is “a space to write about your language
learning activities”.
It doesn’t have to be a physical notebook,
or journal.
In fact, I often use Google Docs for just
this purpose.
Every day, in my language learning notebook,
I write down the language learning activities
that I have done for that day. and these are
usually listening, reading, and translation
activities tied to my Bidirectional Translation
Method, which is what I personally use to
start any language.
Beyond the list of activities, I also ask
myself questions which help me reflect on
the quality of my learning for that day.
These include questions such as:
Do I enjoy my current learning activities?
Do I find them too easy, too difficult, or
just challenging enough?
Can I add or remove anything to make these
activities more effective?
Is there anything I can do to better adapt
these activities to the language I am learning?
Asking myself these questions keeps me from
getting complacent in my learning activities,
and helps me to strive to improve them more
and more over time.
Reflecting in this way helps me not only keep
track of my developing language skills, but
also my developing strategies and techniques
for learning languages, as well.
Ok, so there you have it.
Now you’ve learned the three simple steps
that you can put to use today to start learning
any language.
If you’re interested in learning more about
how I start learning new languages on my own,
check the link in the description box.
You’ll find a link to my brand-new online
course, which teaches the ins and outs of
my very own Bidirectional Translation method!
As always, thanks for watching and happy language
learning!